jingle bells inger buizingen mais alors
c'est pas noël n'est presque presse
pourquoi pu regarder on a le doublé
gagnon lala poko m4 propos qu ex cat
propos quand une quatre roues alors ça
c'est un sujet intéressant parce que
d'une ma caméra n'est pas réglé assez
haut mais ça vous vous en fichez année
c'est juste moi qui vais faire le petit
réajustement bas comme ça je vous fait
profiter tout voyez voyez tout mon truc
n'est pas bien inclinés je veux pas que
vous ayez la tête de travail moyen de
jouer en place voilà ont mis en place
pourquoi une quatre ans intéressant
pourquoi parce que je vous ai déjà
présenté le pot 4 pro il ya quelques
mois novembre 2021 là je tombe cette
vidéo on efface février quasiment début
mars 2022 autant vous dire que pour
comme cadres pro est sorti depuis un
petit moment oui mais c'était la version
5 g et ses chiots mise à me faire des
blagues voici le poème quatre provinces
enquête j adore lui on en parle dans
quelques jours on se le met de côté
aujourd'hui on se concentre sur celui là
on se concentre sur le x4 profa c'est la
vraie nouveauté vraie nouveauté parce
que tu n'as pas eu tous cas de trois
bandits qu'adjani 5 gère ça c'est un x4
pro 5 j'ai peut-être je dis bien
peut-être arrivera-t-il à 6,4 pro 4g
allez savoir aujourd'hui on se parle de
la 5g ans parle du smartphone qui va
aller le plus loin qui fera plus de
choses on va donc lui ouvrir le débat et
on va regarder la performance regardez
la photo on parle du faux mais
honnêtement on s'en fout on est chez
faut qu on veut pas de la photo chez
beaucoup on veut quoi on veut de la
performance on nous à tartines on se
regarde ça même
je regardez moi ça allait on va s'ouvrir
on va regarder en met à nu je vais pas
ouvert je vous ai attendu on se fait
tout en cendres au louvre on le regarde
on le des pioches on y va non déjà
regardé un bout de fiches techniques
poko x 4 au 5 g ça va bien on voit qu'on
a un écran amoled avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 100 verte ça c'est
cool full hd + am oled display c'est le
petit point sont que vous allez avoir
dual speaker dont des hauts parleurs
stéréo du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé c'est très chouette une
caméra principale de 100 8 mégapixels
progrès wade ok on verra mais on
n'échappe aux curieux général la
performance au niveau de la photo c'est
pas trop ça ultra wide et macroule
blends évoqué au niveau de la photo on a
ici un snapdragon processeurs gravés en
6 nanomètres ok est ce qu'ils vous
disent pas c'est que j'ai tout noté ben
ouais je suis un petit malin ici c'est
du 695 grave et en signale hausse et
d'un processeur 5 g puis surtout on est
de la recharge 67 watts avec une
batterie de 5000 milliampères heures
voilà pour côté un peu technique qu'on
va retrouver écrit ce qui nous intéresse
sur célé design parce que tu as ils sont
très jolis chez coco et j'ai bien fait
de vous attendre c'est toujours chouette
j'adore ses effets qu'on a ici au niveau
des reflets des effets de lumière alors
on a vraiment deux parties distinctes
pour voir la première partie avec la
partie photo en haut qui est très jolie
c'est marrant parce que voyez c'est
vraiment de faire ce gros travail poko
alors je vous le dis je vous ai déjà dit
en fait un poco aujourd'hui est une
boîte séparer de chiots mis au niveau
global mais en france xiaomi s'occupe de
poko mais si on regarde je vous ai déjà
fait une vidéo sur la stratégie tuyaux
mais d'ailleurs je vous invite à venir
découvrir ce n'est pas déjà le cas joue
mes liens quelque part par là où dans la
description à leicester et c'est
vachement intéressant de comprendre
comment fonctionnent les gammes ça c'est
une sous-marque de la même manière que
red mis au point de vue global est une
marque indépendante mais qui est une
filiale de chirurgie pour un peu fait un
petit truc un petit peu rapide donc là
on a une caméra principale ici on va
avoir quoi on va avoir joué noter je me
rappelle plus face à un ultra
grand-angle essai de la macro autant
vous dire que c'est pas là où on va
aller le plus loin mais surtout ce que
j'aime bien c'est ce bal à regarder là
c'était fait là c'est super super super
canon g10 reflets lumineux rock sont pas
au bout j'ai pas je vais les virer on va
pas garder des lumières qui nous dérange
voilà on vient les petites lumières
jaunes un peu on veut de la pureté si
vous ne soient claires et pur c'est
super sympa j'adore ce côté là alors
c'est marrant parce que je le connais et
je trouve extrêmement plat c'est pareil
les côtés sont très plat à ces profils
et le design est vraiment hyper hyper
hyper canon j'adore ce côté noir un côté
un peu faussement maths qui prend pas
particulièrement les traces de doigts
assis un peu il ya un bout de gras des
doigts qui reste là par contre sur le
dessus si tout de suite un peu plus un
peu plus évident que ça prend les traces
de doigts et autres caméras principal on
va avoir un petit un petit décroché on a
un petit décroché là aussi donc on a un
double décrocher c'est assez joli un
j'aime bien ce qu'ils ont fait alors sur
le dessus et regardez vous ne voyez que
vous avez une petite prise jack vous
avez ici ça c'est de l'infrarouge pour
utiliser comme une télécommande le micro
pour la réduction de bruit et ça c'est
quoi ça c'est un haut parleur on va
regarder ce que donne la la stéréo de ce
côté-là rien du tout là vous avez votre
tiroir de cartes sim à leurs cartes sim
cartes nanosims 5 g ou une deuxième
année au sim avec ou y laissant des
morts jusqu'à 1 tera de la recharge en
usb c'est votre micro ici est bien
évidemment vos haut-parleurs de l'autre
côté vous avez ici un bouton qui sert à
l'allumer et l'éteindre et qui fait
également office de 14 d'empreintes
digitales et bien évidemment le bouton
de volume et puis un très grand écran
mais pour parler de l'écran on fait quoi
on l'allumé avant de l'allumer on fait
quoi et elle regarde le restant de la
boîte bien évidemment regardez-moi ça 67
watts ça c'est la promesse alors cette
promesse elle est vachement intéressante
pourquoi parce que vous avez ici une
batterie de 5000 méliand paire eur et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui où ils
vous dire ce qu'on veut c'est pour vous
dire ce qu'on ne veut pas on ne veut
plus se dire je ne vais plus avoir de
batterie je vais être bloquée je vais
être embêté alors qu'est ce que font les
constructeurs et notamment chez tommy et
on l'a vu ici avec le 11 tu es pro on a
eu de la recharge 120 oil c'était énorme
là on est un peu en dessous on n'est pas
chez chuo mis en échec beaucoup même si
c'est la même boîte au global on est sur
du 67 3 qui va vous le recharger
extrêmement rapidement je pense que là
vous devez le recharger l equal aller en
un quart d'heure à 50% un truc comme ça
donc ça va aller vite bien côté rasseoir
nom qu'on se pose plus réellement
aujourd'hui la question de l'autonomie
d'un smartphone mais de la recharge en
combien de temps je leur charte si par
exemple je vois que j'ai vingt quinze
pour cent de batterie et bien je viens
prendre se dire branché en combien de
temps je suis reparti sans aucun
problème sur un jour et demi deux jours
c'est vraiment la question donc ça c'est
intéressant et c'est extrêmement
rassurant et bravo pour coup d'avoir
fait ça donc là on prend deux secondes
enfin club dans les mains et je reviens
avec un écran allumé je vous dévoile
tout absolument tout rires ok il est
configuré il est là il est beau il
échoue à regarder j'ai pris le temps de
faire le tour de m'amuser de regarder
alors il ya plein de choses à venir
raconter sur son smartphone alors déjà
d'un point de vue logiciel on va tourner
si sûr me why 13 pour pau comme i way
très c'est la dernière un jour qu'on va
retrouver ici sur les smartphones de
shiomi et notamment ici sur ce
smartphone de poko donc ça c'est la très
très bonne nouvelle c'est très très très
bien il ya deux trois petits trucs à
venir regarder déjà je viens paramétrer
un truc au niveau de l'écran est bien
c'est qu'il arrête de se mettre en
veille on va rester comme ça alors un
truc qui est intéressant et qu'il faut
que je monte c'est le taux
d'actualisation ici je voulais montrer
tout à l'heure on a un taux de
rafraîchissement en 60 hertz on peut
venir le patient 120 hertz pour gagner
le maximum de fluidité dans ce qu'on l'à
venir naviguer scrollé notamment faire
des jeux attention l'autonomie va s'en
sentir bon néanmoins déjà comme ça là on
sent verte c'est pas mal et comme
bouvier le recharger rapidement je le
mets un coup de charges tout à l'heure
eh bien ça lui fait beaucoup de bien et
ça c'est très très chouette alors ici
vous avez un grand écran regardez on a
quand même une très très grande dalle on
est sur du 6,67 poussée de l'amoled on
est sur une résolution full hd plus
qu'on voit tout de suite c'est qu'on a
un menton c'est à dire tout le bal à qui
va être un peu plus grand que ce qu'on
va avoir sur le haut ici on est sur un
smartphone qui n'est pas extrêmement
cher donc c'est pas des conneries je
vous dévoile le prix dans quelques
instants les dispos il ya plein de
choses à bien vous racontez là dessus
donc voilà alors l'écran en lui même je
trouve plutôt joli la luminosité jeu les
pousser à fond que ça pète l'écran le
plus lumineux du marché aux annonces
quoi 710 de luminosité avec un pic à
1210 donc si vous arrivez en plein été
et que vous êtes au soleil à un moment
ça peut être un peu limitatif ça il faut
le savoir un autre coach à savoir c'est
que ça se passe quelque chose un peu
lourd il fait 205 grammes dans le sang
un franchement où laissant les 205 g
sous les doigts alors si vous jouez
comme ça il vaut smartphone est posé sur
une table n'y a pas de souci mais on les
sent après on est dans la norme par
rapport à certains smartphones et je
vous le dis très rapidement il coûte
quoi écoute aller retour de 300 euros je
vous déballe de taille entre deux
instants donc bon ça me surprend pas
après vous avez un corning gorilla glass
5 à l'avancé quoi en fait une techno qui
va venir protéger la vente de
smartphones c'est corning qui fait ça
c'est une marque si vous ne savez pas
c'est leur techno 5 de cinquième
génération qui va venir protéger et bien
la vendre vos smartphones notamment
contre les rayures ok c'est plutôt bien
fait et pour le gaming en plus du tout
infléchissement 120 hertz vous avez un
taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 3 164
ça c'est vraiment un sens d'avoir un peu
de chiffres le truc qui m'intéresse moi
vraiment c'est toute la partie audio
parce qu'on a des haut parleurs stéréo
alors je pas si vous vous souvenez vous
avez parlé du sjao mist et le mit aux
ignares hier il y avait le mythe 10
avant le midi ce projet j'avais beaucoup
aimé le milices pro par rapport à toute
l'expérience audio vous avez trouvé
meilleur sur le smartphone d'il ya deux
ans de shlomi que sur le smartphone de
l'année dernière parce qu'on avait des
haut parleurs stéréo et je trouvais ça
bien alors il y avait également fait des
haut-parleurs stéréo sur le nivôse il y
avait vraiment une spécialisation
pourquoi parce que vous aviez des petits
haut parleurs sur le côté vous aviez les
mêmes en face que sont le chiot 1000
millions vous n'aviez pas et j'avais
trouvé ça un peu dommage alors là vous
avez un peu à même idée au niveau d'un
effet miroir pour une meilleure
socialisation c'est à quelque chose près
ça à quelque chose près pourquoi je
pense qu'en fait le son principal vient
bien de ce côté là avec un son un peu
plus grave avec un spectre un peu plus
largement de la rondeur mais un poil
plus si vous voulez sur le haut parleur
que vous allez avoir de ce côté là le
sont un peu plus étriqué c'est plus dur
en pense et pas aussi étriqué que ce
qu'on pourrait avoir en utilisant juste
le par lors que vous avez là il ya un
côté un peu plus à reims peck qui est un
peu plus là mais on n'a pas une vraie
image parfaite à droite comme à gauche
néanmoins pour un smartphone dans cette
gamme de prix se trouve ça vachement
bien ça me plaît une fois de plus si
vous voulez augmenter l'expérience vous
avez la prise jack qui est là et sinon
vous avez la possibilité de venir
brancher un casque bluetooth avec de
bluetooth cinq points donc on a vraiment
de quoi faire pour ça sur ça cool
l'autre point qui est intéressant sur ce
smartphone est bien c'est la performance
on est chez beaucoup à le regarder je
vais vous montrer un petit jeu histoire
de se mettre dedans et j'ai plus elles
sont un peu fort mais c'est fait exprès
pour que c'est pas mal et en termes de
côté enfin merci ça marche et un truc
est vachement bien alors on va se lancer
une petite partie d'asphalté histoire
d'aller se marrer on va prendre la route
ensemble le temps de vous donner
quelques se paye parce que j'en ai ici
pour combien de savoir réellement qu'est
ce que ce smartphone aux allemands parce
que pau causé du gaming c'est vraiment
des smartphones qui sont faits pour lui
et mila et on part et en même temps je
vous raconte vous attendez voilà je suis
pas coach est d'accord c'est parti
beaucoup c'est parti donc tu n'as pas
bien franchement c'est très cool et
trois ans alors ici on est sur quoi on s
urs la dragonne ses 1 695 5 g a frôlé la
laj éclate de la bagnole on n'est pas là
pour rigoler on va voir soit 6 soit
éligible à mme sylla ltd drk fixe et
vous allez avoir soit 128 x 256 jviens
de stocker en vérité c'est qu'ils
attaquent 2.2 donc on n'a pas été témoin
cité cnoa les plus dingues mais
néanmoins cela semble fonctionner en
titane loyer sera stade neuf n'est pas
non plus le jeu le gourmand du monde on
a un truc qui réactive qui marche bien
qui est très sympa et que je trouve ce
coup là pour venir se marier ici donc ça
nous ira parfaitement bien les autres
avaient été malades vous avez en plus
une technologie de refroidissement c'est
le mythe lui colle une technologie c'est
le 1.0 plus si je vous dis pas de
bêtises qui vous permettra de finir frag
arashima fans notamment à ce que vous
allez jouer pendant de nombreuses heures
pour ça c'est très cool hop là on repart
comme avant l'échec et niche donc un
côté très sympa envoyée il ya du son et
un côté immersif obligé de porter ma
voix et gueuler un petit peu donc en
terme d'expérience de gaming ou un truc
qui marche bien alors on va pas aller
aussi loin que sur les flagships
benevides amant mais ce smartphone il
n'a pas le prix d'un flagship donc on
s'y attend absolument et là-dessus il
n'y absolument aucune surprise donc là
dessus ça me conviendra parfaitement
bien alors apprécier à notre test je les
pousse et surtout tous les stores doit
rappeler que ça racontait et j'ai été
assez surpris par le sort que je
trouvais pas extrêmement élevé regardez
ce classement on est en bas du
classement on est ici à
265 1966 on est en bas de beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup smartphones j'aurais tendance à
penser qu'il ya eu un truc un peu zarbi
parce qu un score aussi bas sur un
smartphone comme ça bon peut-être que le
cendre agon 695 et pas extrêmement
performant je pense que ça pour
expliquer l'histoire ce que j'ai
d'autres poko à mettre en face à voyager
le pot coach trois pros on parle de
l'année dernière un lent déclin sur le x
4 aux intentions voyez donc là il me le
donne quand même à 187 milles donc je
pense qu'il ya eu un petit truc qui n'a
pas fonctionné moment de du benchmark
part en tout dont je vais vraiment
prendre ça avec des pincettes parce que
en termes d'expérience relativement cool
après un autre qu'il faut voir sur toute
la partie photo et vidéo dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure c'est que
regarder en fait là vous le voyez vous
avez trois capteurs le capteur principal
ici 500 8 mégapixels tout vrai 20.9
alors attention c'est que sur le papier
en regard des photos en quelques
instants vous allez voir une techno 2,9
pixels en un pour sortir une photo 12
mégapixels hallyday csn regroupe neuf
pixels pour faire un méga pixels est
venu capter plus de lumière pour les
photos de nuit c'est la promesse qui
fait en tout cas vous avez ici un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels touvre f 2.2
et puis vous avez un capteur de
maquereaux 2 mégapixels couvre f 2.4 je
suis généralement pas très convaincu par
ses capteurs lahonce leur garde donc la
cause instant mais mon avis même si
c'est bien les avoir ça va pas être le
truc le plus dingue du monde et puis
vous avez une caméra de salfit 16
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.4 on va se
regardent également le résultat dans
quelques instants
voilà le résultat photo là on est sur le
grand temps que l'on veut c'est un grand
angle ultra grand-angle zoom x dont on
va pas aller au delà parce que vraiment
c'est pas un smartphone qui est fait
pour aller au delà pour regarder la
macro la caméra de celle fillon va pas
se faire la vidéo parce que c'est pas un
smartphone qui est fait pour faire de la
vidéo on va passer aussi la photo ni
parce que c'est pas un smartphone qui
est fait pour faire de la photo nuit
regarder sur le grand temps que sur le
100 8 mégapixels c'est pas mal
franchement c'est pas mal je ne peux pas
dire que c'est pas bon c'est un peu plat
ça tire quand même bien sûr le jeune et
on le voit aussi au niveau des bâtiments
ça me manquait un peu de contraste mais
dans l'ensemble le boulot est bien fait
et là dessus je vais rien venir reproché
à poko sur ce capteur principal l'ultra
grand temps que c'est moi ça alors il ya
plusieurs choses à venir raconter on
voit qu'il ya un travail qui a été fait
je trouverais sans doute un peu de
déformation direction les anglais se
soit pas parfait mais on va retrouver un
ciel qui va être à s'ébruiter et plus on
va venir à l'extérieur et moi ça va être
précis c'est un ultra grand temps que
c'est normal mais regardez vous allez
voir on va continuer là on passe en x 2
alors ce qu'on va faire comme on n'a pas
de tels objectifs on va venir croquer
dans l'image dans votre capteur de 8
mégapixels c'est pour ça que vous aurez
des résultats qui sont pas mauvais mais
on va pas aller au delà parce qu'après
on va vraiment venir dégrader la qualité
de l'image on continue comme ça sur le
capteur principal vous voyez que là les
bâtiments sont quand même bien éclairé
c'est pas cramé on a bien les zones
d'ombré on retrouve ce côté un peu jaune
sur la photo qui est quand même
relativement typé mais ça fera le taf et
vu positionnement tarifaire du
smartphone c'est convenable
ultra-grand-angle toujours la même chose
on va notamment au niveau du ciel on va
récupérer beaucoup de bruit voyez sur le
côté il semble plus bas soit côté et
plus et pire là au niveau des nuages on
l'a également au centre bon alors là le
cycliste forcément il bouge donc ça va
pas être extraordinaire on a du bourg il
a donc c'est avec ces images elles sont
bruts et ont donc beaucoup de bruit ici
c'est pas très beau et comme on a aucune
stabilisation sur aucun objectif comme
sa dette brute et que ça bouge voyait ça
apporte un peu de flou de flou de bougé
c'est pas au froid c'est pas ouf et en
plus la regarder le niveau des hautes
lumières il a un peu plus de mal bon
c'est du travail entend et on va pas
trop trop lui en vouloir voyons on peut
venir zoom et un petit peu on va
récupérer du monde là sur la façade on
va en récupérer la voilà c'est pas c'est
pas fait pour donc on est quand même sur
je vous le dis on vient où mais non
l'image au niveau de votre capteur
principal cette photo là c'est pareil
capteur principal au niveau de la
gestion des hautes lumières c'est pas
mauvais bonds toujours un peu les mêmes
reproches la lutte sera grand temps que
c'est pareil c'est pas dingue alors là
on a vraiment fait un effort sans
capteurs placés par exemple kg une zone
d'ombré je vais vraiment venir voir si
ça vient compenser est ce que mon
clocher est cramé et alors voyez c'est
intéressant parce que pour autant on n'a
pas un clou c'est cramé pour autant on
voit quand même ce qui emballe or ce
n'est pas un traitement qui est parfait
c'est pas vaillant vous seriez sur un
smartphone plus haut de gamme vous aurez
plus de détails sur la blouse varié plus
de choses mais dans l'ensemble ça va si
vous passez sur l' ultra grand-angle la
gestion des hautes lumières voyez ici je
trouve pas mauvaise mise à part le fait
que c'est une image qui est bruitées
donc pour quelques souvenirs avec de
bonnes conditions de luminosité en
regardant le rendu sur l'écran de votre
smartphone sera mais sur un ordinateur
c'est beaucoup moins ça là j'ai testé
voyez j'ai regardé le zoom en faible
luminosité on récupère un peu de bruit
sur le bâtiment et lorsqu'on va sur le
clocher qui tout de suite mieux exposés
parce que plus de lumière s'est tout de
suite un petit peu mieux bien qu'on
récupère encore un peu de bruit dans le
ciel on continue ici joue un peu les
mêmes romains voyez puis sur l'ultra
grand
toulouse reste assez intéressant parce
que on est sur le capteur principal et
vous voyez quand même qui à côté un peu
cramé je trouve ici parce que vous avez
un côté qui est beaucoup plus sombre là
un côté qui éclaire un peu plus moyen
est là le soleil a vraiment tapé fort
sur cette façade qui est un peu plus
blanche donc tout de suite l'expo est un
peu moins bonne c'est un peu les limites
du truc faut vraiment venir le chercher
dans ses retranchements et comme on est
sur une zone plus dont ici voyez on
attaque du bruit qui vient on le voit
notamment sur le camion volant que les
limites de ce capteur principal l'ultra
grand temps que bongo la gestion
d'autres lumière là-dessus là il s'est
mis à genoux il n'y est pas arrivé et
puis on dirait zoomer c'est pas pire
donc bon ça fera halte à fond soit 2 la
caméra de celle ci n est pas très bonne
et ça c'est un truc qu'on va souvent
séché omis pour causé le traitement
niveau dépôts qui a un peu trop lisse et
là je trouve bruitées alors là je vous
ai fait des photos sans hd est resté
sans hdr photo st h dr on voit que la
façade arrière est complètement cramé et
d'exhumer le hdm massa récupère quand
même pas mal sur la peau ça vient
également attrapé mais voyez c'est un
espèce de grain de peau qui pas beau du
tout il ya un côté faussement lisse et
un peu mort huit équipes à beauvois je
trouve pas ça terrible terrible c'est
avec une expo plus forte derrière sur 1
un contre jour ça rattrape mais c'est
pas beau et les couleurs sont pâles et
donc on peut faire des fautes on sait le
fil pour aller les souvenirs ne va pas
s'extasier devant la macro j'ai fait des
soutes vite fait mais franchement on se
met relativement loin des courses mais
proche ça marche pas il rendu juste pas
pourquoi donc en fait vous avez un
capteur le capteur principale leçon 8
mégapixels pour venir faire des photos
pas mal mais pas mieux c'est un
smartphone qui est certifié ip 53 pour
la résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
attention ce n'est pas une résistance il
pèse 68 on va aller moins loin en termes
de résistance néanmoins on va éviter de
le jeter dans sa piscine on va éviter
d'aller se baigner avec ton s'est pas
fait pour mais ça assure quand même une
certaine résistance donc un côté
rassurant vous avez du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé je voulais dit
également vous avez l'infrarouge pour
mieux l'utiliser comme une télécommande
et vous avez une double vanos team et
également 5 g et une anodine + 4 me
croiser jusqu'à un terrain si vous
souhaitez alors les tarifs et alger là
je vous les donne son aval sur ma
feuille taille c'est très intéressant là
je vous parle du x4 pro et je vous
parlerai dans quelques jours du mk pro
4g va forcément être moins cher que
modèle 5g qu'on a vu il ya quelques
temps alors il faut savoir que dans la
gamme poko la gamme x et le milieu de
gamme on a deux conflits qu une config
628 et 8 256 la version 6 128 go de
stockage vous êtes à 299 euros quasiment
300 euros et la version
8256 on est à 349 euros et seront
disponibles à partir du 2 mars et je
vous mets les biens bien évidemment dans
la description pour pouvoir dire les
trouver très facilement alors voilà sur
le principe à ce smartphone je trouve
plutôt bien si vous n'avez en usage
plutôt axé gaming si vous voulez un très
grand écran si vous voulez une bonne
expérience audio comme ça sans casque
sans rien c'est plutôt bien pour du
multimédia vous avez un écran dégagé qui
rateraient bien du 120 hertz également
qui sera plutôt bien pour le gagner donc
pour l'expérience gaming on a un truc
qui conviendra je mets un petit bémol
sur la partie processeur que je trouve
bien mais attention au jeu qui va
demander beaucoup de ressources pas
forcément sur ce smartphone là qu'il
faudra aller on va venir couverts quand
même je dirais quasiment l'étendue de
tous les jeux qu'on va voir sur le ps
store donc sans trois donc de
l'expérience multimédia la trouvent
bonne le fait d'avoir ce bloc de charge
qui est énorme là ça ça me rassure
vachement quand même ce 67 soit parce
que bien que vous ayez madrid 5 millions
terreur avec vous le savez les 5000
millien par heure il leur faut un petit
peu de temps pour revenir se remplir eh
bien vous avez de quoi recharger très
rapidement donc là c'est vachement cool
l'autonomie va varier en fonction de
vous usage si vous jouez énormément mais
forcément on n'aura pas des masses mais
une fois de plus 67 oil de recharge
rapide donc c'est plutôt cool pensait
alors on est avec vous alors ça rajoute
du poids bien évidemment lorsqu'on met
dans les bagages il est un petit peu
l'eau se moque de charge mais bon voilà
67 soit ici relativement normal
là-dessus l'autonomie je vous dis un
jour un jour et demi ça va dépendre de
vous et vos usa côté photo on est chez
coco 1 c'est pas un smartphone qui va
être fait pour faire de la photo même si
on peut en faire avec le capteur
principal et puis voilà les usages on
est sur un usage mixte peut avoir deux
cartes sim d'avoir une extension de
mémoire qui fut surtout me why 13 pour
focaux qui est très coulée qui marche
bien donc je trouve plutôt intéressant
j'aurais tendance à dire que même la
compliquer 628 même si c'est pas là où
on va voir le max de fluidité même si on
pourra aller jusqu'à 8 c'est déjà très
bien à moins de 300 euros trouve ça bien
alors si vous voulez la machine la plus
puissante chez aux comptes s'étaient pas
celle là qu'il faudra mais si vous
voulez un smartphone un peu moins de 300
euros chip locaux et pas mal à vous de
nous dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire comment vous trouvez vous
ce x 4 3 5g ils peuvent vous tentez pas
vous tentez est ce que vous aimez la
boîte déjà mais le design est ce que
vous avez sous moi j'aime bien ce look
derrière la voyez j'ai déjà commencé à
tracer quelques petites traces de doigts
on va venir se rendre compte un peu
voyez mais bon voilà c'est c'est un
smartphone c'est classique et dans cette
gamme de prix a rien qui me surprend la
tulliste déverrouille rapidement c'est
c'est un joli ce matin dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire moi
je vous embrasse selon nous très vite on
va continuer à parler de chiots me de
poko bien évidemment du mk2 pro 4g d'ici
quelques jours donc abonnez-vous ce
n'est pas le cas et puis très bientôt le
chien mais 12 va arriver enfin mais on
va regarder ce qu'ils racontent le
flagship de 2022 xiaomi à mon avis ça
envoyer du bois d'ici là prenez soin de
vous on brasse a très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]